[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here back with
another tech video
kinda
let's talk about dogecoin so you might
have seen this all over twitter for the
past couple of weeks or months this
seemingly random crypto coming out of
nowhere coming from a few fractions of a
penny all the way up to a few cents on
its way to who knows what powered by
rocket emojis shiba e news and elon musk
tweets kind of random but in the tech
world it's it's been kind of fascinating
to watch what's been going on here
and so on this topic that i think i
would i would normally have on my
podcast on on the waveform podcast
shameless plug um i felt like it would
make a fun video to sort of unpack how i
look at what's been going on here
this video is not official financial
advice i'm not an expert it's not the
type of thing you should probably get
from a youtuber anyway but i'm not
responsible for anything you may do or
decide to do
after watching this video so okay
dogecoin is a cryptocurrency so in order
to understand basically what's happening
with it you should understand what
cryptocurrencies are and so i'll just
use bitcoin the most prominent one as my
example here so bitcoin's been around
since 2009 it's the most prominent
largest uh crypto by market cap but to
oversimplify it's basically a
decentralized digital currency it's an
unregulated highly volatile
digital currency built on blockchain but
of course bitcoin's not the only one
there are tons of other
currencies based on the same thing but
like based on alterations of the same
rules so they're alternate
coins they're called altcoins and
there's a lot of them the thing is
almost anyone can make an altcoin
eventually like it's actually fairly
impressive how easy it is to make and so
there are tons of them and they're all
built on like different little tweaks
and versions of the same fundamentals
and pretty much all of them will claim
to be
better than bitcoin in some way
debatable but there's a lot of them out
there which is the point and uh you
might have heard of some of these so
there's ethereum there's litecoin
stellar
ripple
dash
neo
you can literally just open up coinbase
and sort through tons and tons of them
and this is just a small fraction
there's at this point i'm going to say
probably thousands of different altcoins
to pick from and they're all basically
trying to give you some reason for them
to catch on some reason that they're
better than bitcoin to invest in or use
and then
there's dogecoin
dogecoin was literally started as a joke
as a tweet by jackson palmer while he
was walking at adobe sort of literally
making fun of how many alt coins there
were like oh what imagine there was this
shiba inu powered doge coin and the coin
had a little picture of the meme on it
and it just kind of hooked on a lot and
got traction from there it's like one of
those jokes that catches on so much it
becomes more than the joke it like
outgrows itself and it becomes a real
thing so he collaborated with billy
marcus from ibm and uh they gave it a
logo registered it launched it built the
thing
and now it's real so okay fundamentally
we know what dogecoin is as an alternate
crypto but i think the reason that it's
caught back on and stuck around for as
long as it has
is much more interesting to me see the
thing you start to notice about
cryptocurrencies is
they all take themselves very seriously
and they should because they're they
exist in different worlds for great
reasons i actually really like the idea
of bitcoin i think having like a global
currency makes sense in the age of the
internet we live in but now that there
are so many altcoins it can feel kind of
overwhelming to sort through them all
and find out which ones are useful which
ones are good short-term
versus long-term investments which ones
you can buy that may actually make you
money that's what everyone wants to know
and everyone kind of like stocks
everyone wants to find that hidden gem
of like a young smaller crypto that has
just the right combination of things
that it's going to grow and turn into
this massive important thing and so that
gets people investing in all kinds of
small very young crypto that eventually
gets you in the murky waters of possible
scams and and pump and dump schemes and
things that you probably shouldn't be
investing in so dogecoin
seems like it's caught on
because it started as a joke and then
and now people are taking it super
seriously but also kind of as a joke but
also kind of for real does that make
sense so graham stefan who knows way
more about finance than me made a really
great video about dogecoin like a day or
two ago
where and i'll link his video below you
should watch the whole thing but he
makes a really great point which is that
because it started as a harmless joke
and because it's obvious the founders
aren't really doing this for the money
and it's just such a sort of a jokey
thing in its origin that actually makes
it in this world of crypto that takes
itself super seriously
it makes it more
accessible it makes it less intimidating
it makes it more likely to succeed
because of how obvious it is that
they're not trying and so graham brings
up this example of the same thing with
someone named will rogers who ran for
president in 1928 and won on a joke
campaign and then eventually resigned
could have been president but the whole
point of his campaign was to show how
dumb it was and mock the whole process
and so that was like the dogecoin of
politicians but i also have an example
of like the equal but opposite situation
um in my own inbox i got an email about
sponsor potential sponsorship
integration
and i i say no to 99.999
of the emails that i get about stuff
like this but i always like to hear them
out in case there's potential in this
deal let's figure out what it is so i
get this email so this one said they
just wanted to tweet and that they
already have participation from lindsay
lohan amanda cerny neo
lil yachty and more
i'm i'm like
all right that's an interesting group
it's an interesting email
so
okay what what is the campaign for and
it turned out it's for
tron
a cryptocurrency that they're
i guess paying people to tweet about and
clearly they care a lot about people
caring about it if they want lindsay
lohan to promote it i guess i mean i
don't i don't know who gets their
financial advice from
nevermind but the more i read into this
email the more sketchy it is they
mention they're often referred to as the
ethereum killer whatever you say uh and
that they need to make it look like it's
not a sponsored tweet and then they
linked three example tweets
one from lindsay lohan
neo and lil yachty
which i clicked on none of which were
even marked as an ad by the way like i
hate i don't i'm not trying to call
people out on this but that is pretty
cringe behavior but the point of me
bringing this up is this is this is like
the opposite end of the the dogecoin
strategy where they clearly take
themselves way too seriously where they
have people with stakes in it paying
people to talk about it to hopefully get
it more attention and to boost volume
and to boost prices and a strategy like
that comes off as so insincere and so
try hard that like just look at the
comments everybody people are already
turned off by it actually people kind of
hate it and so dogecoin on the other
hand is is being boosted literally by
people meaning online
and the owners because i think they
realize that it's never been meant to be
taken that seriously have just been
using that press and using money they
get from it from for honestly the best
causes possible they've used the press
to their advantage and have donated
gains to meaningful causes like they've
donated fifty thousand dollars to raise
awareness of kenya's water crisis and
graham stefan pointed out 25 000
to get the jamaican bobsled team to the
olympics that is a cool runnings movie
reference
incredible movie hilarious movie if you
haven't seen it you should
just making sure everybody caught that
but the point is
the it felt like it felt like the crypto
for the people like the more accessible
less intimidating version for the people
the smaller price made it ideal for
things like uh micro tipping on social
media websites like reddit would let you
just tip in dogecoin if you wanted to
and then lately of course elon musk
seems to be really enjoying it um i mean
we've he's always been
specifically into like memeing on
twitter for a long time anyway uh but
obviously he's he's all in like if you
look at his twitter over the past like
month or two it's just been all dogecoin
and then if you watch the price and
volume of dogecoin go up the more he
tweets about it and then it'll sort of
simmer down and die off after a while
and then he'll tweet about it again and
it'll it'll kick up i bet if you drew a
volume graph of how many times people
trade and talk about it it would be your
right lock step in line with elon's
tweets
that's just the way it is but hey in
this world of unregulated
decentralized cryptocurrencies that's
fair game so at least now we understand
the memes about dogecoin going all the
way up to a dollar i think it's at like
five and a half cents right now
something like that do i think it'll
ever get up to a dollar
probably not
but again
this isn't financial advice but anyway
in summary
dogecoin
has caught on
as an altcoin but also as a meme not
just because people seem to be rallying
against wall street against that's the
whole big financial
institution that's kind of had its way
forever but also because of the meme
and like the doge himself i feel like
this meme has a longer shelf life than
most it feels like the currency of
internet attention
now as far as if you should invest or
not this video is still not financial
advice so again i'm not responsible for
anything you may do or think about doing
after watching what i say but i think it
is actually a fun
harmless cryptocurrency to at least get
started with and and begin to mess
around with to understand the inner
workings of how it works how the trading
works what apps you like to use things
like that i wouldn't invest any money
that you're uncomfortable with turning
to zero dollars because it could
but i think once you're done messing
with that then you can take those
learnings and apply it to other future
investments because it's always a good
idea to have a diverse set of
investments that's financial 101
but in the meantime
it feels good to be in on the joke now
feels good to understand it
people are going to ride this either to
the moon
or till it dies because that's what the
internet does with every joke
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]